Flexbox, is one of the most powerful
tools that you can use for layout.
It's changed a lot in the last
couple years, but at this point,
it's hit candidate recommendation and
it's supported by most browsers.
In this class, I'm just going to
show you the current syntax.
But, in your code and for
anything you're building.
For production, I want you to make
sure that you're including all of
the vendor prefixed version.
So that way,
if anybody's on an older browser,
you're not leaving them out in the cold.
>> The reason Flexbox is so powerful.
Is its ability to fill
the space available.
If an element has extra room around it,
it'll expand to fit or if it's getting
crowded elements will shrink, so
that they take up as
little space as possible.
Let me show you an example.
Flex box makes it super easy to position
elements left or right, without floats.
You can also change the order of
elements, without changing HTML,
and flex box makes it really
easy to accomplish a lot of
other common layout techniques.
Pete, how do you approach
design with flex boxes?
>> Well, let me show you.
>> Cool.